village à l'organique est avec nous
yannick merci d'avoir accepté de
dépasser un peu de votre temps notre
compagnie pour parler d'un problème qui
vous préoccupent vous aussi beaucoup
vous avez constitué une association avec
votre mère c'est ça il y en a pas
vraiment constitué une association
d'intégrer à l'association care son
coeur ou et qui travaille depuis pas mal
de temps déjà dans les pays du
tiers-monde et disons que nous avons
commencé il ya il ya trois ans de
manière pas très intensive et maintenant
dix ans que ma mère s'en occupe à plein
temps et de temps en temps nous faisons
des opérations alors vous vous êtes
lancé dans ce type dette parce que parce
que vous êtes africains aussi ou parce
que vous et en étant un garçon connu
riche vous êtes dit il faut que je fasse
quelque chose pour mes frères bien il ya
peut-être de cela d'un jeu plupart je
suis peut-être sensibiliser de par le
fait que je viens de cp et de ce1 de ces
pays là mais là unique raison est la
vraie la raison pour laquelle je
m'occupe de ça c'est que d'abord j'étais
inspiré qu'un parent à monsieur qui
s'appelle bob geldof qui a fait quelque
chose d'assez fantastique et l occ ce
concert du live aid qui est un moment
extraordinaire où pendant toute une
journée des gens du monde entier se sont
réunis ont regardé la télévision écouter
de la musique des meilleurs artistes du
monde se donner la main et se serrer les
coudes pour une cause et je pense c'est
un moment tellement fantastique que ça
vous faire des yeux à pas mal de gens
pas mal de jambe dans la situation de
ses musiciens
et quand je dis ce genre là je parle de
d'acteur de cinéma d'artistes c'est des
gens que je considère comme des gens de
prix visé privilégiés dont je fais
partie et c'est pour ça que dans la
mesure où j'ai beaucoup voyagé j'ai pu
voir à travers tous ces voyages que il
ya effectivement des endroits où et des
gens qui n'ont pas la chance qu'on a je
me suis dit que c'était tout à fait
naturel que je m'en occupe il se trouve
que oui j'ai été inspiré par pas mal de
deux choses où il se trouve
effectivement je suis également africain
et qu'il ya un problème au nord cameroun
puisque le décider de le désert descend
depuis emplissent yannick je vais
pouvoir acheter ta raquette de mal bon
j'espère tu va l'acheter j'espère faire
l'a payé très cher surtout
il faut le dire il faut nous dire à quoi
vous faites référence tous les deux la
raison qui l'a mérité ce que vous faites
des lianes demain demain après midi
nous avons de 2h30 ou trois heures
d'antenne durant laquelle on va montrer
ce que fait notre organisation qui
éclaire donc ils travaillent à peu près
d'après ce que j'ai vu jean loup de la
même façon que son organisation
bon va également montré un fils faire
faire connaître car nous on fait on sert
de tampon concert de temps pendant la
séance où les gens savent qu'il ya des
problèmes mais eux ils savent pas où ils
savent pas comment venir en aide et
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
privilégier ya beaucoup de gens qui
n'ont pas de problème il ya beaucoup de
gens qui n'ont pas faim est bon nous
sert un peu ah bon parce qu'on a un nom
parce qu'on ait connu justement les gens
viennent nous voir et à partir de là on
leur montre le film on leur montre ce
que font ces organisations à ce propos
je peux te couper les seconds oui excuse
moi
à ce propos une des choses que mes amis
du comité français contre la faim dans
le monde
mon monde est une des choses les plus
simples et les plus scandaleuses c'est
que il y a officiellement beaucoup plus
qu'il n'en faut à manger sur la terre
pour la population terrestre
on n'est pas trop nombreux une question
de répartition est évidemment c'est de
cette répartition qu'il s'agit de
s'occuper
je rends la parole excuse moi absolument
que se crée tout à fait raison je
continue en fait ce qu'on va faire en
plus de sa parallèlement à ce film et on
en est on y est une algue une animation
où il va y avoir une vente aux enchères
tous les sportifs que j'ai contacté mon
donner quelque chose à vendre alain
prost m'a donné son cast en été champion
du monde
michel platini m'a donné son maillot de
l'aj et 28 sont mal l'équipe de france
et puis rocheteau qui m'a filé également
son son maillot et c'est donc il y aura
une vente aux gens vous enchères et est
ce que ce régime irais je compte bien
essayer d'acheter sa raquette mais ce
que je pourrais acheter ta première
balle de service
pas chez moi si tu lui as perdu tu l'as
tu l'as travail peut-être pas d'âge et
lower exact sophia antipolis savent à
part ça ça va très bien je me prépare là
pour roland roland garros dans quelque
temps mais surtout pour monter un mot la
semaine prochaine nous savons que
actuellement à aniston joue que le
double je me demandais si là je vais
jouer je jouais vaincu éliminé on n'en
parle pas en option
j'étais en forme yannick vous sentez
bien là pardon vous êtes enfant me
sentais bien pour le hangar aux jeunes
filles roland garros est encore un peu
loin c'est encore de six en cinq
semaines ça va le faire rome d'abord il
ya monte-carlo ensuite forrest hill
surtout la naissance de mon deuxième
gosse et puis après après roland garros
si sûre malgré mashaal un coup de
téléphone nous savons que tu veux pas
que scratch jeu que tu quittes en
courant le terrain je tente peut-être un
ace alors si la balle accrochant le
filet tu quittes le terrain en courant
et comme tu sais le règlement interdit
d'y revenir
j'ai disqualifier un grand grand
finisseur de tennis jean louis goût suis
atteint pk 18 ans chez lui mais il avait
un passeport américain et puis quand il
aura 18 ans il choisit rails pour être
camerounais suédois français et
américains je pense que gilles ragot à
bâle iii balle pas mal merci beaucoup
yannick d'avoir participé en pleine de
midi très bientôt en tout cas on va